this is from the daily wire it says
earlier this month two black
penn state university professors
reported seeing a noose in a tree behind
their house
they told psu student newspaper the
daily collegian that the incident was
deeply distressing to them and their
family
media outlets uh media outlet the center
daily times reported that the professors
believe the alleged noose was
deliberately placed on the tree to
harass them
the college fix reported that the patton
township police department found the
noose and began investigating
before that investigation was complete
however uh psu president eric barron
posed a statement condemning
the alleged act of hate and accepting
the professor's feelings as truth
baron wrote quote the incident
underscores the importance of our
anti-racism work as a university as
a community of scholars it also
underscores the importance of our town
of our town work to build a safe
welcoming and inclusive environment for
all who live here
when police spoke to professors
neighbors they learned the truth okay so
that's
that's that's that's the setup and
just to review okay we've got two black
uh university professors
who see quote unquote a noose in a in a
tree behind
what they really saw by the way they saw
a rope they just happened to see a rope
and the immediate assumption now is that
if you're black and you see a rope
anywhere it's it's it is a suspected
noose
and someone planted it there as a hate
crime
and so then we had the police
investigating and
the psu president condemning the rope
this is the worst rope
this rope is hateful and bigoted well it
turns out um
after police investigated that um the
rope was not a hate crime
it was part of a swing set that had been
attached to the tree it was just a swing
set
which uh you know i i don't have we
could probably find a picture of this
rope i don't have it in front of me i'm
not sure what to look like
um but i'm guessing
first of all what we know is that if it
was if it was part of a swing set it
wasn't an
actual noose
okay it may have been a rope with kind
of like a loop at the end of it
which is where you would attach the
swing but that's not a noose
not every rope that's hanging from
something is a noose in fact i go this
far
almost every rope you know
there's no way for me to confirm this
but i'll make this statement anyway
pretty provocative
almost every rope that is currently
hanging from something
in this country right now is not a noose
now you go even further there's a high
likelihood
that none of them are hate crimes
all of the ropes probably thousands and
thousands of ropes currently hanging
from various things
for various reasons and none of them are
hate crimes
because there are so many practical
reasons why human beings hang ropes from
things
one of them is a so i gotta i gotta
wonder
these two um college professors
you send your kids to be taught by these
people and they've never heard of a
swing set in a tree
they never encountered that in their
life
when they were told about the swing set
they said what what do you mean a swing
what
swing what is that
you're saying the children will will sit
on this contraption
and swing back and forth i've never
heard of such a thing
these two poor people i mean they've
been going to playgrounds their entire
lives and thinking that
they're witnessing a clan meeting
they've never heard of a swing before
or or you know the other possibility is
that uh
they're not lunatics and they damn well
knew that most likely this rope that
they saw
is has a perfectly innocuous explanation
like a swing
but they decided to run with it anyway
in order to score some victim points
that's the other possibility you know
it's really one of those two
so either they are absolute lunatic
idiots or um
they're just disingenuous frauds you
know to me those are the two most likely
possibilities and i say that again i
haven't seen the rope
i guess every time i see one of these
things i wonder where
we have heard of so many cases of ropes
being mistaken for nooses that were
supposedly
hate crimes including in bubba wallace's
garage
remember there was a there was a garage
door pull someone
it's just a rope used to pull open a
garage
and the fbi what do they say they sent i
think they sent 15
fbi agents to investigate the rope
so that we've heard of that many other
cases like that
and in every case that we hear about it
turns out that the rope had some
innocuous purpose
like a swaying a garage door pull
whatever crack there was another case in
cracker barrel
it wasn't even a rope it was just a it
was a cord
from like an from like an antique
soldering iron
and it happened to be hanging there and
the assumption was that it was a noose
so a lot of cases like that and they all
turn out to be
fraudulent or hoaxes or
misunderstandings
has where are the real cases of this
does this
ever happen in reality in fact the whole
idea of a
noose as a as a racist
symbol has it ever been a racist symbol
i don't think it has the left just
invented this
it's kind of like the okay side which i
just did right there so you know media
matters is going to be on top of that
the okay sign that you make with the the
the left just decided that this is a now
going to be a
a symbol of hate it never has been
there's no precedent for that they they
just decided it
and they did the same thing with the
news
yes now it's true that that historically
nooses have been used in murderous and
racist ways that's true
um but going back for thousands of years
ropes and even nooses have had
innocuous uses
and also sometimes murderous uses or
executing people and
oftentimes had nothing to do with race
at all
so the idea that it's now exclusively a
racist symbol where does that come from
uh it just mainly comes from the media
it's a media invention
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated